hey guys it's kate from voice correct
katie's going through second puberty is
that menopause
hey guys it's katie and i'm here with my
husband chris hello and i have made mini
donut cereal before it was really good
but after that chris was like i wish
you'd make lots of things mini like that
should be the thing you do yes and i
need everything no but now i'm doing it
so
great so i wanted to know what do you
want me to make minnie next
oh
i think i want mini apple bust
when you say apple pie you mean like a
whole little pie think about a normal
regular average sized pie
apple pie and what that looks like and
then just envision a mini tiny baby
little
petite fatigue
i want petite pies petit fives tea pies
tiny quarters out of this
there is no way out
[Music]
[Laughter]
so the first thing i'm going to make for
these mini apple pies is the filling and
i'm going to cook it ahead of time
because i don't know how long these are
going to take in the oven to bake it
might be really quick this just
guarantees that our apples get cooked so
first thing we have is a pan over medium
heat and i'm going to melt three
tablespoons of butter and once our
butter's melted i have one large apple
here that i've peeled sliced and diced
so we'll add that in
and we'll saute that for a couple
minutes just until i get tender in the
butter so now i'm gonna add some sugar
of course you gotta have the cinnamon
some nutmeg a pinch of salt and then i'm
going to take some water and cornstarch
i'm mixing the cornstarch in the water
ahead of time so that we don't get
clumps in our mixture here add that
and we'll let this cook for another two
to four minutes just until our sauce
thickens up and our apples cook a little
bit more and because it's always good to
taste as you go i'm gonna take a little
bit and see
that's good you know what it could
almost be a tad sweeter or maybe i just
have a sweet tooth i'm gonna add a
little bit more sugar and i think that
will be it we'll let that dissolve in
there she is glistening she is ooey she
is gooey i think our filling is ready so
let's move on to the part that scares me
the most let's do it let's do it let's
go i'm ethel merman
next thing i have to work on is the
crust i could make this from scratch but
i'm going to take a shortcut i always
like to save some time and i'm going to
use store-bought pie dough which
generally tastes pretty good and i'm
shaming no one who does this no shame so
i'm gonna sprinkle this with some flour
and then roll it out a little bit
thinner
now the next question you might be
asking is katie what are you gonna bake
this in so i have this jar
which you might be like whoa
what but the cap of these little jars
are the perfect little apple pans these
came in a pack of 20 so now i have a
bunch of jars that i could fill with
spices tell me in the comments what you
would do with 20 of these jars make a
pinterest or give me ideas so this is
our pie dish but i want to cut circles
that are a little bit larger than them
so the cap to my cooking spray is the
perfect size and i am just going to take
this
press down
and cut out 40 circles
we want one for the base crust and one
for the top crust
now i'll lay out all my jar lids on a
baking sheet then i'm going to spray
these guys with vegetable oil to make
sure the crust doesn't stick so we'll
take our little baby crusts
and we'll just we're going to place it
into the base
and there's our first little pie
it is cute so i'm just going to repeat
this 20 times
my bottom crust is done so now i'm going
to add a teaspoon of filling
all the pies are filled so now i have to
make the top i really want to do a
lattice because i think that would look
very cute very neat but could be very
tricky so i have my 20 remaining dough
circles and i'm going to just cut them
into thin slices i'll use four strips to
make the lattice we'll criss-cross that
and then use a fork to help seal the
edges then i'll take scissors to cut off
the excess first one was challenging
looks pretty cute i like him he's little
i'm just gonna keep repeating this and
do it 19 more times no big deal
[Music]
i've assembled all the pies they're
killing me with their cuteness last
thing i need to do is add some egg wash
so it gets nice and golden brown okay
they're all egg washed assembled i'm
gonna go put them in the oven at 450
degrees fahrenheit and i'm going to
check them every five minutes so they
don't burn
so while the pies are baking we're gonna
make a meringue why are we making a
meringue because it looks like whipped
cream and i think it'd be really cute if
all these little pies look like they
have a dollop of whipped cream on top so
making a meringue is fairly easy you
just gotta make sure you have room
temperature egg whites i'm adding a
little bit of cream of tartar and this
is just gonna help stabilize and then
we'll add a pinch of salt we're gonna
whisk these eggs until they get nice and
foamy and form soft peaks then we'll add
granulated sugar just a little bit at a
time if you do it too fast you're going
to deflate your eggs you're going to let
that mix on high until the eggs get nice
and shiny and we get stiff peaks another
way to know you're done is if you can
take this bowl hold it over your head
and nothing falls you don't have to put
it over your head i guess
doesn't have to be that risky so i'm
gonna go put this in a piping bag and
we're gonna pipe out little whipped
cream dollops they look like little
chocolate chips i'm gonna go bake them
in the oven at 200 degrees fahrenheit
for about 40 minutes to an hour until
they're all the way dried through and i
can easily peel them off let's do it
guys the pies are baked they're cooled
and they are so cute so the last thing i
want to do is pipe on a little bit of
frosting to each to act as the glue to
stick on our meringue
these guys are finished they're so
adorable i can't wait for chris to see
them i'm gonna put these little babies
in a bowl and serve them as cereal and
then we'll see what chris thinks chris
open your eyes
those look like real fancy pies that's
fancy schmancy
uh so you want to try it
absolutely that's a beautiful looking
pie
so you ate that all in one bite
that is great piyo's the the cereal that
makes you go oh that's good
eat the piles now until you cry it's
time to eat those pies did you just eat
the pies till you cry
oh yes
you